nach vorn verlor gerd welche themen
neben dem krieg in der ukraine
beschäftigen die fraktionen diese woche
ja da gibt es tatsächlich noch das eine
oder andere thema auf dass ich gleich
kommen wird aber natürlich ist der krieg
in der ukraine das hauptgesprächsthema
nach dem massaker in butscher da stellen
sich doch entscheidende fragen für das
deutsche parlament aber natürlich auch
für die bundesregierung und natürlich
ist die bundesregierung vor allem im
ausland unter kritik geraten wegen der
fehlenden konsequenz bei der frage
energielieferungen aus russland
robert habeck der wirtschaftsminister
das ja gestern nochmal dargestellt wie
notwendig die lieferungen aus russland
für die deutsche volkswirtschaft sind
allerdings hat die
verteidigungsministerin zum beispiel
gestern gesagt also sie ist der meinung
da müsste jetzt konsequent reagiert
werden nach den gräueltaten in butscher
und diese diskussion zieht sich hier
heute natürlich durch alle fraktionen
alles was da dran hängt
waffenlieferungen auch die frage woher
man die alternative energie so schnell
besorgen soll und auch die frage wenn es
wirklich so weit kommt dass europa eine
möglichkeit nach der anderen aus stellt
jetzt also sozusagen kein keine kohle
mehr aus russland dann muss man schnell
handeln als deutsche regierung und
versuchen diese löcher zu stopfen vor
einigen hinblick auf den herbst damit
nicht die wohnungen in deutschland kalt
bleiben die folgen sind heute
unübersehbar jetzt schon wird der
bundesfinanzminister wissen dass das ein
teures jahr werden wird aber es gibt in
der tat auch andere themen zum beispiel
die leute darüber informieren und im
herbst dann entscheiden dass eine
impfpflicht 50 kommt da hat diese andere
gruppe gesagt wir bewegen uns auch diese
zu indem wir eine impfpflicht ab 50
allerdings ab jetzt dann sozusagen
fordern jetzt geht's los mit rolf
mützenich dem fraktionsvorsitzenden der
spd hört sich wird ein dann kommen wir
zu den fragen ja meine damen und herren
vielen dank für ihr interesse
in dieser sitzungswoche dienstags
fraktion in dem sie gesagt haben wir
werden ein impf register aufbauen das
ist eine der zentralen forderungen auch
der union und zum beispiel die gruppe um
den fdp ab gesundheitsminister
ullmann die gesagt hat wir wollen eine
impfpflicht ab 50 ab dem herbst wenn wir
vorher
die leute darüber informieren und im
herbst dann entscheiden dass eine
impfpflicht 50 kommt da hat diese andere
gruppe gesagt wir bewegen uns auch diese
zu indem wir eine impfpflicht ab 50
allerdings ab jetzt dann sozusagen
fordern jetzt geht's los mit rolf
mützenich dem fraktionsvorsitzenden der
spd fühlt sich für ein dann kommen wir
zu ihnen fragen ja meine damen und
herren vielen dank für ihr interesse
in dieser sitzungswoche die mit
sicherheit wieder
herausfordernd sein wird was die
themenstellung betrifft und letztlich
eben auch insbesondere
auch themen die abgeordnete in gruppen
anträgen fällt leicht dazu noch etwas
sagen vorangebracht versucht haben
voranzubringen ich möchte natürlich
zuerst zum krieg in der ukraine so das
was an verschiedenen orten
offensichtlich nicht nur was gegen
internationales völkerrecht sondern
gegen alles was man bisher auch so aus
kriegen scheinbar gesehen hat verstößt
und es ist notwendig dass wir hier alles
dafür tun dass die sowohl
verantwortlichen aber auch die
hintergründe aufgeklärt werden bin der
festen überzeugung dass deutschland
sowohl im hinblick auf seine forensische
und auch rechtliche und unterstützung
wenn es dann eine internationale
aufklärung vielleicht durch eben den
internationalen strafgerichtshof gibt
auch unterstützend wirken können ich
habe schon mehrfach darauf hingewiesen
dass der krieg alleine aber eben auch
die persönliche verantwortung von
präsident putin ein kriegsverbrechen ist
und dass der internationale
strafgerichtshof von sich aus bereits
ermittlungen eingeleitet hat ist richtig
ist unterstützenswert uns dass zum
beispiel jetzt auch die us regierung in
dieser richtung forderungen erhoben hat
deckt sich mit anderen partnerstaaten
bei dieser gelegenheit aber auch sagen
ich würde mir dann natürlich auch
wünschen dass die us regierung alle
möglichkeiten ausschöpft eben dass auch
die usa mitgliedsland des
internationalen strafgerichtshofs werden
müsste genauso wie die volksrepublik
china indien es gibt immer noch viel zu
viele staaten die von dieser möglichkeit
gegen schwerste kriegsverbrechen
menschenrechtsverletzungen vorzugehen
abstand nehmen uns dass wir noch mal
eine deutliche unterstützung für die
europäische position
umso wichtiger ist dass heute auch die
eu kommission vorgeschlagen hat dass es
zu keinen weiteren lieferungen von kohle
von energie aus russland kommen soll wir
schließen uns diesen boykotts an und von
daher glaube ich dass auch weitere
sanktionsmöglichkeiten
geprüft werden müssen auf der anderen
seite ist es insbesondere so dass wir
darauf achten sollen dass gerade die
mitgliedsländer der europäischen union
an dieser frage nicht auseinandergehen
deswegen sind auch verabredungen sehr
wichtig zum anderen möchte ich natürlich
darauf hinweisen das ist eines der
herausragenden themen die wir neben der
ukraine krise wo morgen der
bundeskanzler mit sicherheit in der
regierungsbefragung aus sicht der
bundesregierung auch noch mal eine
stellung
name geben wird und wir auch eine
aktuelle stunde dem anschließen werden
zu den vorfällen wir auf der anderen
seite natürlich die frage der
allgemeinen impfpflicht oder spezieller
im pflichten im deutschen bundestag
jetzt zur abstimmung stellen in diesen
stunden und auch in
meiner absicht bis zum schluss werden
wir alles versuchen dass es ein
kompromiss gibt zwischen den
verschiedenen gruppen bin dankbar dass
die gruppe um dagmar schmidt dirk wiese
heike behrens und anderen aus meiner
fraktion mit anderen aus der fraktion
der
grünen noch mal kompromissvorschläge am
montag unterbreitet hat die verschiedene
elemente aus den anderen anträgen
beinhaltet und umso wichtiger ist dass
wir jetzt alles unternehmen eine breite
mehrheit für eine impfpflicht die
möglicherweise abgestuft von alters her
ist auch
vornehmen das sind vielleicht so die
drei wichtigsten aspekte und nicht
stehen natürlich wiederum für fragen zur
verfügung
herbstein hatten
ja in welcher reihenfolge am donnerstag
abgestimmt wird ist eine klärung
zwischen den pdfs erfolgt inzwischen die
bundestagsverwaltung hat uns zwei
vorschläge gemacht wir neigen sehr stark
einen dieser vorschläge zu der das
bedeutet dass zuerst über die anträge
und dann über die gesetzentwürfe
abgestimmt wird ich finde das
nachvollziehbar die anträge
sind natürlich auch von ihrem inhalt her
belastbar aber die gesetzentwürfe haben
ja auch gerade in den anhörungen eine
rolle gespielt und da finde ich dass
gerade die gesetzentwürfe in der
schlussabstimmung sozusagen also als
letztes auch im deutschen bundestag
aufgerufen werden sollten dazu würde ich
auch meiner fraktion eine empfehlung
geben weil wir wahrscheinlich im
deutschen bundestag über die reihenfolge
und dem abstimmungsverhalten dann
entscheiden werden müssen
naja der gesetzentwurf wird ich dann mal
sagen der von der gruppe ullmann und von
der gruppe die ich eben benannt hat die
zurzeit die größte unterstützung im
deutschen bundestag hat die würden dann
zum schluss aufgerufen und ich wünsche
mir dass die gruppe die die größte ist
mit dem gesetzentwurf dann auch zum
schluss abgestimmt wird
kollege
ja
bundespräsidentin frank walter
steinmeier hat gestern weitreichende
fehler mit blick auf seine persönliche
russland politik in den letzten jahren
eingeräumt inwiefern sind diese
eingeständnisse aus ihrer sicht
ausreichend in einem mit der aktuellen
situation also ich finde das was der
bundespräsident aber was die
bundeskanzlerin und andere geäußert
haben eben vor dem hintergrund des
kriegseintritt
überfalls russland auf die ukraine
natürlich das nochmal gewichtet was
heute der fall ist und ich finde sehr
beachtlich dass der bundespräsident sagt
das natürlich in der einschätzung fehler
gemacht worden sind wenn man alles das
hätte vorhersehen können was präsident
putin ohne rücksicht auf sein land auf
die menschen in russland auf die
wirtschaftliche entwicklung jetzt
entschieden hat weil wir sehen ja was
die sanktionen für auswirkungen haben
letztlich aber auch die chancen auf eine
gemeinsame zukunft die gleich null sind
insbesondere mit einem präsidenten putin
ist das auf jeden fall eine wichtige
stellungnahme es ist aber auf der
anderen seite so dass wir uns
vor dem hintergrund der kriegsgräuel auf
jeden fall eben auch das was ich gesagt
habe dem internationalen
strafgerichtshof alle möglichkeiten zur
verfügung stellen müssen gegen putin und
letztlich auch seine unterstützer
vorzugehen auf der anderen seite sind
fragen der internationalen politik auch
weiterhin insbesondere
menschheitsfragen wie die der
klimapolitik und viele andere dinge auch
in zukunft nur in einem internationalen
rahmen zu behandeln ob russland in
zukunft überhaupt dazu bereit sein wird
das werden wir zu prüfen an zurzeit geht
es ganz konkret darum dass dieser krieg
in diesen minuten stunden mindestens in
tagen enden muss
damit sich zwei fragen zum thema ukraine
nämlich einmal was sanktionen angeht da
hatten sie gesagt sie unterstützen kohle
seien also kohle embargo kann ist
richtig verstehe bezieht sich das nur
auf kohle oder auch auf gas und öl und
eine zweite frage zu den
waffenlieferungen wo es für sie die rote
linie war ja jetzt der ukrainische
botschafter heute morgen zum beispiel
auch die lieferung von leopard-panzern
gefordert hatte also ich habe eben ganz
bewusst natürlich auch nochmal
befürworte das was die europäischen
partnerstaaten auf den weg bringen was
sie letztlich jetzt im hinblick auf die
energielieferungen sagen wir brauchen
ein abgestimmtes verhalten das begrüße
ich und ich glaube das ist auch wirksam
das ist ein deutliches zeichen was dort
gesendet wird alle anderen dinge werden
mit sicherheit auch in den
regierungskonsultationen zu prüfen sein
und zu den waffenlieferungen hier bin
ich sehr überzeugt davon dass die
bundesregierung alles prüft was möglich
ist an waffenlieferungen und letztlich
auch was verantwortbar ist und ich will
sehr deutlich sagen die angriffe die
gegen die verteidigungsministerin immer
wieder in den letzten stunden und tagen
gemacht worden sind sind überhaupt nicht
haltbar und sie entbehren auch jeder
grundlage zusammen mit dem
bundesverteidigungsministerium
unternimmt sie alles die möglichkeiten
zu schaffen damit die ukraine aufgrund
das selbstverteidigungsrecht durch die
charta der vereinten nationen eben auch
waffen von deutschland aus bekommt nach
meinem kenntnisstand ist deutschland
durchaus einer der größten geber in
diesem bereich insbesondere auch neben
den wirtschaftlichen hilfen die wir
bereits ja schon in den letzten jahren
gegeben haben das darf man nie vergessen
ja gefragt hatte speziell auch nach gas
und öl das haben sie jetzt nicht erwähnt
in ihrer antwort heißt das dass könnte
ihrer meinung nach auch in dem
sanktionspaket mit drin sein denn jetzt
ist ja heute an diesem tag genau das
offensichtlich auf den weg gebracht
worden was ich erwähnt habe alle anderen
dinge müssen sehr gut abgewogen werden
und sie wissen dass insbesondere nicht
nur die wirtschaft sondern auch die
gewerkschaften aber auch die
bundesregierung genau darauf wird achten
müssen was weitere entscheidungen in
diesem bereich betrifft das kann
natürlich nicht sein dass wir in
deutschland deutschland schwächen den
wirtschaftsstandort deutschland
schwächen dass wir in einer massive dann
auch rezession aber auch inflation gehen
würden mit bestimmten entscheidungen
dennoch bin ich der festen überzeugung
wird vieles auch abgestimmen zwischen
den europäischen regierungen und das ist
gut
jetzt bin ich eine flächendeckende
massen pflicht haben wir aufgehoben
quarantäne regelungen sind dann ab mai
wahrscheinlich in weiten teilen ja auch
selbstverantwortung
ausgerichtet und gleichzeitig arbeiten
wir an einer gesetzlichen grundlage für
eine impfpflicht ist das nicht ein
widerspruch und wenn nein warum nicht
nein die impfpflicht ist natürlich
insbesondere auf den herbst hin
orientiert wo wir davon ausgehen müssen
dass die infektionszahlen insbesondere
dann wenn es wieder zu erneuten
mutationen kommt und ich muss wirklich
sagen solange es in der welt keinen
weltweiten schutz keinen verlässlichen
schutz auch gegen bestimmte varianten
gibt ist es ganz klar dass auch europa
spätestens nach dem sommer auch mit
solchen herausforderung konfrontiert ist
das eben bestimmte maßnahmen das wissen
sie im infektionsschutzgesetz am ende so
zusammengeführt worden sind dass sie
auch einen kompromiss dargestellt haben
das ist so ich hätte mir bestimmte
weitere basisschutz maßnahmen gewünscht
habe ich nie zweifel daran gelassen und
umso wichtiger ist dass die menschen
nicht nur eine einsicht haben in die
eigenen auch möglicherweise
dinge die sie selbst mit entscheiden
können daran appelliere ich auch
zurückhaltung und ich glaube dass
insbesondere auch weiterhin das masken
tragen für den einzelnen aber auch
gegenüber der gesellschaft einen
basisschutz ist und ich kann das jedem
nur empfehlen
soweit also der
spd-fraktionsvorsitzende die spd ist für
eine impfpflicht der bundeskanzler hat
ja schon im herbst vergangenen jahres
gesagt im märz wird diese impfpflicht in
deutschland kommen
nun ist der gruppenantrag dem man muss
hier in gruppen abstimmen also die
abstimmung freigeben in den fraktionen
weil die fdp nicht mitzieht die ampel
hat also keine mehrheit nun ist hier der
gruppenantrag den vor einigen spd
politiker hier eingebracht haben eine
allgemeine impfpflicht wohl nicht
mehrheitsfähig deswegen hat man diesen
modifiziert und versucht auf die anderen
gruppen zuzugehen und das dürfte ein
wirklich spannendes abstimmung szenario
werden am donnerstag drei anträge und
zwei gesetzentwürfe liegen vor und viele
beobachter sagen anschluss wird keiner
dieser fünf dinge die mehrheit bekommen
und wir warten jetzt auf die cdu
deswegen kann ich ihnen das noch mal
schnell auseinander nehmen die afd wird
ein antrag am donnerstag vorlegen darin
sagt sie impfen taugt nichts keinerlei
impfpflicht wolfgang kubicki und andere
legen einen antrag vor und sagen impfen
ist sehr gut für den einzelnen jeder
sollte sich impfen lassen aber bitte
keine impfpflicht
die cdu liegt ein gesetzentwurf vor der
vorsieht dass man erst einmal beraten
muss und in einem zweiten schritt dann
im herbst sehen muss ob eine impfpflicht
dann eingeführt werden soll der
mechanismus soll aber schon etabliert
werden abgeordnete um den
fdp-abgeordneten gesundheitspolitiker
ullmann sagen man muss alle menschen
beraten und im herbst muss man als
bundestag dann abstimmen ob die 50
jährigen aufwärts also die wohlhabenden
gruppen geimpft werden sollen und dann
ist der spd antrag der eben sagt
impfpflicht für alle und jetzt
modifiziert wurde man will jetzt das
50-jährige aufwärts auf jeden fall
geimpft werden so das sind die fünf
anträge und jetzt geht's los mit
verboten kommen vielen dank dass sie
unserer einladung gefolgt sind wir haben
heute in der fraktionssitzung zwei große
themen das eine ist das thema
impfpflicht dass wir ja am donnerstag
aller voraussicht nach im plenum zur
diskussion und zur abstimmung gestellt
haben und das zeit ist das thema
unverändert und leider die ukraine und
der krieg dort ich will mit diesem thema
beginnen wir alle sehen die bilder
dieses schrecklichen krieges jetzt in
der fünften woche
wir sehen vor allen dingen die bilder
aus butter und anderen vororten von kiew
anderen städten und plätzen die von der
russischen armee
offensichtlich verlassen werden und dort
viele tote und traumatisierte menschen
hinterlassen es kann nach diesen bildern
nun wirklich überhaupt kein zweifel mehr
bestehen dass die russische armee
schwerste kriegsverbrechen begeht an der
zivilbevölkerung dort und aus unserer
sicht gibt es daraus drei
schlussfolgerungen zu ziehen das erste
ist die internationale
staatengemeinschaft muss die
kriegsverbrecherprozesse die diesem
krieg folgen müssen vorbereitendes
müssen beweise gesichert werden es muss
auch der zugang internationaler
organisationen insbesondere des
deutschen roten des europäischen und
internationalen roten kreuzes ermöglicht
werden um hier auch beweise zu sichern
für spätere verfahren aber bevor wir so
weit sind müssen auch maßnahmen
ergriffen werden um diesen schrecklichen
krieg zu beenden wir beschäftigen uns
heute in der fraktion noch mal mit dem
thema waffenlieferungen es mehren sich
die berichte und die hinweise darauf
dass die bundesregierung nicht die
waffen liefert die sie behauptet zu
liefern es sind ja auch in den
fernsehnachrichten der letzten tage
immer wieder auch zahlen genannt worden
ich will eine von gestern abend noch
einmal in erinnerung rufen dass
angeblich über 60 panzer der firma
rheinmetall zur abholung bereit stehen
und von der bundesregierung nicht
genehmigt werden zur ausfuhr in die
ukraine wenn das so sein sollte dann ist
das wirklich ein großes versäumnis der
bundesregierung und ich möchte den
bundeskanzler von dieser stelle aus
auffordern das jetzt selbst in die hand
zu nehmen und dafür zu sorgen dass nicht
das wirtschaftsministerium das
verteidigungsministerium das
außenministerium sich hier gegenseitig
die verantwortung zuschieben das ist
chefsache der bundeskanzler der nun
wirklich mit großem nachdruck alles tut
jedenfalls behauptet alles zu tun um
diesen krieg zu enden zu beenden mit den
mitteln die wir haben muss dies in die
hand nehmen und darf es nicht sein
streiten den ministern weiter überlassen
das nächste thema sind die sanktionen
sie bekommen mit dass es dazu intensive
diskussionen auch in der europäischen
kommission gibt aus unserer seite aus
unserer sicht ist richtig den import von
kohle sofort zu stoppen es scheint
möglich zu sein die kohle die aus
russland nach europa geliefert wird
sofort zu substituieren aus unserer
sicht ist es notwendig die importe von
öl in kürzester zeit zu beenden es
scheint möglich zu sein auch hier öl in
ausreichendem umfang zu substituieren
und das dritte ist wir bleiben bei
unserer position die da lautet gas aus
russland zu reduzieren und so schnell
wie möglich den gasbezug auch zu beenden
das ist aus unserer sicht das wichtigste
was wir heute aus unserer sicht als
schlussfolgerung aus diesem weiter
eskalierenden krieg in der ukraine
ziehen können das zweite thema das uns
in dieser woche beschäftigt ist die
impfpflicht sie alle wissen dass wir
dazu einen eigenen antrag in den
deutschen bundestag eingebracht haben
wir sind nicht nur nach wie vor sondern
mehr denn je davon überzeugt dass dies
der richtige antrag ist er steht auch in
einem kontext mit dem
infektionsgeschehen wenn jetzt an diesem
wochenende nach einer übergangszeit die
masken pflicht in deutschland mehr oder
weniger wegfällt und wenn am ersten mai
die quarantäne pflicht für die
infizierten wegfällt dann kann man nicht
zwischendurch jetzt eine sofort in kraft
tretende impfpflicht beschließen das
passt nicht zusammen
wir haben deswegen nach wie vor die
feste überzeugung sind der festen
überzeugung dass unser antrag richtig
ist alles zu tun um jetzt eine spätere
impfpflicht vorzubereiten dazu gehört
das imwf register dazu gehören aber auch
alle arbeitsrechtlichen
sozialrechtlichen folgen auch das
ordnungswidrigkeitenrecht entsprechend
auch auszugestalten damit man dann eine
impfpflicht einführen kann in
deutschland wenn es zu einer neuen mut
bekommen sollte und wir sehen dass wir
möglicherweise im nächsten herbst erneut
vor erhebliche einschränkungen
gestellt wären zb zu weiteren lockdown
wir nehmen die sorgen und auch die
großen bemühungen des deutschen
einzelhandels besonders ernst die uns in
den letzten tagen immer wieder gesagt
haben wir müssen alles tun um einen
doktor im herbst zu vermeiden ja das ist
auch unsere meinung und wir wollen alles
dafür tun dass das nicht
notwendig wird abschließend ich will
ganz ausdrücklich die koalition davor
warnen am donnerstag schon in der
reihenfolge der abstimmungen eine
manipulation ford zu nehmen im hinblick
auf dieses thema wir erhalten hier
mehrfach hinweise darauf dass die
koalition beabsichtigt mit ihrer
verfahrens mehrheit eine abstimmungs
reihenfolge festzulegen die gegen alle
gepflogenheiten des deutschen parlaments
verstoßen würde nämlich erst unseren
antrag zur abstimmung zu stellen und
dann einen anderen es gibt andere
anträge die weitergehen und die
weitergehenden gehören zuerst zur
abstimmung und nicht unserer hinter
unserem antrag können sich auch
diejenigen versammeln die vorher im
deutschen bundestag keine mehrheit
bekommen haben noch einmal ich warne die
koalition davor hiermit verfahrens
mehrheit zu manipulieren an den
abstimmungs an der abstimmungs
reihenfolge im deutschen bundestag wir
sind gesprächsbereit wir bleiben
gesprächsbereit auf der basis unseres
antrages wir sind natürlich
kompromissbereit aber wir halten weder
eine sofortige einführung einer
impfpflicht mit dem donnerstag noch eine
entsprechende untersuchung oder eine
entsprechende
gespräche und beratung durch die
krankenkassen für angezeigt wenn wir im
herbst vor neue probleme gestellt sind
sollten wir vorbereitet sein auf eine
impfpflicht die dann in kraft tritt und
genau das ist unser vorschlag und der
gehört er am donnerstag nicht nur auf
die tagesordnung sondern als zweiter
oder dritter antrag in die abstimmung so
vielen dank alexander
vielen dank liebe friedrich merz meine
damen und herren diese beispiellose
zivilisationsbruch wie wir ihnen leben
von seiten russlands in der ukraine der
fordert reaktionen und zu diesen
reaktionen gehört auf der einen seite
dass wir noch mal verstärkt bei den
waffenlieferungen auch als
bundesrepublik deutschland tätig werden
und zum anderen dass man im bereich der
sanktionen weitere maßnahmen ergreift
bei den waffenlieferungen haben wir das
gefühl dass die bundesregierung zu wenig
zu spät liefert und nicht darüber redet
und das wird auch nicht damit besser
wenn der parteivorsitzende der spd am
sonntag im fernsehen gegenüber der
öffentlichkeit erklärt dass doch alle
wissen dass man mehr liefert als
öffentlich bekannt ist ich frage mich
wie er zu dieser erkenntnis kommt er ist
nicht teil des sicherheitsrates er ist
nicht teil des sicherheitskabinetts
er hat nach unserer kenntnis keine
detaillierten weiteren inhaltlichen
erkenntnisse als wir die haben können
von daher stellt sich die frage wie er
zu so einer erkenntnis kommt und welche
zusätzlichen
waffenlieferungen erde meinen würde aus
der ukraine ist uns nicht bekannt dass
zusätzliche waffenlieferungen aus
deutschland dort angekommen wären von da
ist da dringend aufklärung notwendig bei
den aussagen die hier von seiten der spd
getroffen werden ich glaube dass wir in
dem alexander dobrindt der landesgruppen
vorsitzender der cdu der csu pardon ich
muss da jetzt ein bisschen dazwischen
grätschen denn wir haben ja noch mehrere
andere fraktionen unter anderem
natürlich die fdp christian du der
fraktionsvorsitzende hat sein statement
vor der fraktionssitzung ebenfalls mit
den gräueltaten im boccia angefangen
es ist schwer die richtigen worte zu
finden wenn wir die nachrichten
ausputzer hören und die schrecklichen
bilder von dort sehen das ausmaß des
leides der menschen in der ukraine
übersteigt jede vorstellungskraft die
ein mensch haben kann und die
kriegsverbrechen die uns derzeit
erschüttern zeigen putins angriffskrieg
hat wieder eine neue eine noch brutalere
dimension erreicht und ersten berichten
zufolge ist butscher ja nicht der
einzige tatort sondern auch in anderen
städten gibt es diese gräueltaten in der
ukraine
und mit blick auf russland ist das eine
erneute zäsur ich sage ganz deutlich
putins regime hat sich unwiderruflich
aus dem kreis der c realisierten
mitglieder unserer staatengemeinschaft
verabschiedet die bundesregierung und
ihre partner werden gemeinsam reagieren
und neue sanktionen auf den weg bringen
das haben sie bereits vernommen dazu
finden ja fortlaufend gespräche auf
europäischer ebene statt zudem müssen
wir das sage ich auch deutlich als
ampelkoalition in reaktion darauf
darüber sprechen die ukraine mit
weiteren waffenlieferungen in diesem
furchtbaren konflikt zu unterstützen ich
will zu der debatte um ein energie
embargo auch einiges sagen wir müssen
grundsätzlich unsere wirtschaftlichen
beziehungen zu russland schnellstmöglich
beenden deswegen bin ich froh dass sich
die europäische union geeinigt hat an
dieser stelle und ein kohle embargo
gegen russland auf den weg bringen wird
das findet die ausdrückliche
unterstützung der fraktion der freien
demokraten man muss gleichzeitig an
erkennen in welchem dilemma sich auch
die ampelkoalition als bundesregierung
derzeit befindet die politik der
vergangenen jahrzehnte leider maßgeblich
geprägt auch durch die union hat uns in
eine massive russische abhängigkeit
gebracht von rohstoffen das kann man und
ich sage leider nicht von heute auf
morgen ändern
aber und das wissen sie die
bundesregierung arbeitet buchstäblich
tag und nacht daran genau das jetzt
endlich zu ändern
wenn wir über ein energie embargo
sprechen da muss uns immer bewusst sein
wir müssen mit den schritten die wir tun
als westen und das auch vereint wie
beispielsweise bei diesem kohle
entsorgung wir müssen das tun was
russland insbesondere dem regime von
wladimir putin mehr schadet als es uns
stark schadet denn sonst hätten wir in
der sache insbesondere für die menschen
in der ukraine nichts gewonnen alles was
wir tun muss darauf gerichtet sein
menschenleben zu retten denn jetzt geht
es nicht um symbole meine damen und
herren und ich bleibe bei einer
wichtigen feststellung unserer
geopolitische stärke ist unsere
wirtschaftliche stärke und die spielen
wir derzeit auch aus und das werden wir
auch in der zukunft tun das war der
erste punkt den ich ansprechen wollte
zur aktuellen lage der ukraine und der
aktuell schrecklichen bilder die uns
alle erreichen und es fällt mir schwer
einen zweiten punkt auf anzusprechen der
aber in dieser sitzungswoche und
natürlich auch innenpolitisch
beschäftigen wird denn richtig es auch
die cola pandemie ist nicht vorbei und
deswegen wird der deutsche bundestag in
dieser woche über das thema impfpflicht
debattieren
ich glaube es war im nachhinein richtig
dass wir uns die zeit genommen haben in
den ausschüssen zwischen den
verschiedenen antragstellern über das
thema impfpflicht intensiv auch in
expertenanhörung zu sprechen es ist gut
dass wir uns diese zeit genommen haben
um auch jetzt mehr klarheit in der
entscheidung in der
gewissensentscheidung für jedes mitglied
des deutschen bundestages zu haben diese
woche kommt das verfahren nun zu einem
abschluss am donnerstag wird der
deutsche bundestag eine entscheidung
treffen zur abstimmung am donnerstag
will ich sagen als erstes wird über das
verfahren gesprochen werden und auch
entschieden in welcher reihenfolge die
anträge und gesetzentwürfe dann
abgestimmt werden
zuerst unserer auffassung nach sollte
über die anträge abgestimmt werden und
dann über die zwei gesetzentwürfe ich
selbst bin dabei nach wie vor eine
entscheidung für mich selbst als
abgeordneter zu treffen denn diese woche
das haben sie gehört ist da noch viel im
fluss insbesondere die gesetzentwurfs
antragsteller sind ja noch in gesprächen
und viele gespräche wurden auch zwischen
den verschiedenen antragsteller bereits
in dieser woche und in den vergangenen
wochen geführt
meine persönliche einschätzung zum
ausgang ist ich vermute dass es schwer
werden wird eine mehrheit im deutschen
bundestag für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht zu finden und das sage ich
jetzt nicht als vorsitzender der
fdp-bundestagsfraktion sondern als
abgeordneter christian dürr sie wissen
dass ich persönlich einer impfpflicht
sehr skeptisch immer gegenüber gestanden
habe und einer solchen allgemeinen
pflicht werde ich nicht meine zustimmung
geben welche man trage ich am ende näher
trete das mache ich auch davon abhängig
wie die gespräche jetzt im weiteren
verlauf so viel von meiner seite
mit den meisten fdp-abgeordneten ist
eine impfpflicht nichts zu machen das
ist ja auch das dilemma was hier die
ampel regierung vorgefunden hat die
ampel fraktion stehen einfach nicht
hinter einem antrag deswegen wird das
ein kompliziertes verfahren werden am
donnerstag ist es nicht ausgeschlossen
dass am schluss keiner der anträge eine
mehrheit hier im deutschen bundestag
findet katharina dröge ist eine der
beiden fraktionsvorsitzenden der
bündnisgrünen auch sie hat sich vor
ihrer fraktionssitzung geäußert
uns alle haben am wochenende die
grauenhaften bilder die grauenhaften
nachrichten aus der ukraine aus butter
erreicht furchtbare verbrechen der
russischen armee gegenüber zivilisten
tote die auf strassen liegen ganze
familien die ausgelöscht wurden
massengräber die gefunden wurden es sind
eigentlich bilder die nicht auszuhalten
sind und auf diese nachrichten kann und
muss es eine antwort der welt geben und
deswegen haben wir als grüne und auch
als bundesregierung schon am wochenende
gesagt dass es weitere noch schärfere
sanktionen gegen muss gegen russland das
die auch in dieser woche noch getroffen
werden müssen und dass die europäisch
abgestimmt sein müssen und da haben auf
der anderen seite gesagt dass es sehr
wichtig ist dass der internationale
strafgerichtshof in den haag schon
ermittlungen aufgenommen hat dass
diejenigen die verantwortung tragen für
diese verbrechen am ende auch vor
gerichten sich rechtfertigen müssen und
deutschland wird sowohl finanziell als
auch personell die arbeit des
internationalen gerichtshofs
unterstützen und wir werden auch die
ukraine weiterhin unterstützen in ihrem
kampf in ihrer recht auf
selbstverteidigung und das heißt auch
dass deutschland weiterhin waffen
liefern wird dass deutschland mehr
waffen liefern wird um die ukraine in
dieser zeit zu unterstützen und russland
muss eins ganz klar sein wir werden
diese unterstützung so lange fortsetzen
so lange es dauert so lange es nötig ist
putin sollte unsere entschlossenheit hin
nicht unterschätzen und wir werden auch
daran arbeiten jeden tag mehr dass die
fossilen importe aus russland dass der
im dort von gas kohle und öl stoppt wir
arbeiten jeden tag daran dass das
schneller geht und ich weiß dass auch
robert habeck jeden tag versucht die
handlungsspielräume zu erweitern für
diesen stopp der importe in jeder sparte
und so früh wie möglich und auch nach
dem wochenende sagen wir noch mal
gemeinsam das wird schneller gehen
müssen und in dem jetzt beispielsweise
die gas infrastruktur der deutschen
gazprom-tochter unter die treuhand der
bundesnetzagentur gestellt wurden sind
wir noch mal einen wichtigen schritt
vorangekommen
mit blick auf eine weitere
unabhängigkeit von russland aber es gilt
gleichzeitig auch bei diesen sanktionen
die unabhängigkeit von den fossilen das
ist keine maßnahme die man kurzfristig
aber machen kann und dann wieder lassen
kann sondern es muss klar sein wir
wollen dauerhaft und grundsätzlich
unabhängig werden von den fossilen aus
russland deswegen ist es eine maßnahme
die wir so ergreifen dass sie dauerhaft
auch funktioniert die durchgehalten
werden kann und die von der bevölkerung
auch unterstützt wird und wir tun jetzt
gleichzeitig alles dafür um in der lage
zu sein unabhängig zu werden von den
fossilen importen aus russland das heißt
einkauf von fossilien aus anderen
regionen der welt das heißt auch ausbau
von energie infrastruktur was bedeutet
natürlich insbesondere ein schnellerer
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien und
mehr maßnahmen um energieeffizienz auch
voranzubringen dort sind wir im letzten
koalitionsausschuss mit blick auf gas
ein großes einen großen schritt
vorangekommen
es wird aber gleichzeitig auch ein
drittel der wärme wird von den privaten
haushalten genutzt beim gas und da sind
wir ein stück weit auf die mitwirkung
aller bürgerinnen und bürger in diesem
land angewiesen das kann die politik
nicht regulieren es gilt einfach für
jeden in diesem land bitte leisten sie
den beitrag den sie können drehen sie
ihre heizung ein stück runter das hilft
uns den gasverbrauch zu reduzieren das
hilft uns unabhängig zu werden von
russischer energie
gleichzeitig sehen wir dass unabhängig
werden von fossilen und der ausbau der
erneuerbaren nicht allein eine
sicherheitspolitische frage ist das hat
der bericht in dieser woche noch einmal
gezeigt die klimakrise verschärft sich
das zeitfenster um die klimakrise zu
bekämpfen schwindet und deswegen jede
regierung auf dieser welt alle maßnahmen
ergreifen die möglich sind um
voranzukommen beim thema klimaschutz und
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir auch
hier in deutschland mit dem ausbau der
erneuerbaren einen großen schritt machen
werden mit dem oster paket jetzt und mit
dem sommer paket an als zweiten schritt
wir tun hier nicht mehr als den größten
schritt seit erfindung des eeg mit dem
ausbau der erneuerbaren und das dritte
thema über das sie sprechen möchte weil
es den bundestag in dieser woche auch
sehr intensiv beschäftigen wird ist die
abstimmung um das thema impfpflicht wir
haben hier mehrere anträge zwei
gesetzesentwürfe im rahmen eines gruppen
verfahrens oder ich persönlich habe
immer gesagt dass ich eine impfpflicht
ab 18 unterstütze weil ich davon
überzeugt bin dass wir in der
verantwortung sind vorsorge zu treffen
für den herbst die menschen zu schützen
und unser gesundheitssystem vor
überlastung zu schützen gleichzeitig
gibt es sehr viele unterschiedliche
positionen im deutschen bundestag und
deswegen ist es richtig dass wir
zwischen den abgeordneten auch nach
wegen suchen wie kompromisse aussehen
können um am ende tatsächlich zu einer
breit getragene lösung zu finden dass
sie mir nicht sehr froh dass es jetzt
einen neuen kompromissvorschlag gibt
über den im bundestag gerade gesprochen
wird und er vielleicht und hoffentlich
eine brücke ist für viele abgeordneten
dann zu einer gemeinsamen lösung auch zu
kommen ich sage allerdings auch ganz
klar in richtung der unionsfraktion als
wir in der opposition waren haben wir
immer gesagt der umgang mit einer
globalen pandemie ist kein thema für das
spiel zwischen regierung und opposition
jeder abgeordnete ist gefragt danach zu
entscheiden was in der sache richtig ist
so haben wir das in der opposition
gehandhabt und diese ernsthaftigkeit
würde ich mir ehrlich gesagt auch von
der cdu und csu wünschen
aber in der sache sehen dass die meisten
bundestagsabgeordneten ganz anderes als
katharina dröge eine impfpflicht ab 18
die cia unterstützt diesen gruppen
antrag der jetzt modifiziert wurde die
wird es schon mal nicht geben am
donnerstag der modifizierte antrag sieht
unter anderem eine impfpflicht ab 50 vor
alice weidl und tino keller die beiden
fraktionsvorsitzenden der afg wir sind
gänzlich gegen jede impfpflicht die afd
bringt einen antrag ein und sagt impfen
taugt nix und impfpflicht schon nicht
schon erst recht nichts alles weitere
haben diese woche im bundestag die
debatte um die allgemeine impfpflicht
die ja jetzt irgendwie doch nicht kommen
soll aber dann irgendwie doch durch die
hintertür also das was als kompromiss
dort rausgekommen ist es natürlich eine
absolute blamage für die ampelkoalition
das ist punkt 1.2
ist das hier auch die schlüsse gezogen
werden müssen was wurde eigentlich vor
den bundestagswahlen versprochen alle
parteien waren ganz klar gegen eine
allgemeine impfpflicht dann kaum im amt
wurde genau dieses projekt und nur das
vorangetrieben und jetzt da das ganze
ding wirklich blamabel gegen die wand
gefahren ist
bemüht man sich um eine ich kann es
nicht anders sagen um eine schrott
lösung wie die impfpflicht ab 50 was
soll das muss man sich fragen was soll
das das bevölkerungsgruppen das
altersgruppen gegeneinander ausgespielt
werden eine impfpflicht ab 50 ist ja
genau das eine impfpflicht und eine
impfpflicht ist ganz klar
verfassungswidrig das haben wir immer
als afd fraktion gesagt als afd partei
dabei bleiben wir eben auch es ist ein
eingriff in die körperliche
unversehrtheit
die gesamte fragestellungen rund um die
nebenwirkungen sind auch noch nicht
beantwortet das fängt jetzt gerade erst
an und darum waren wir auch von anfang
an um die systematische erfassung
derselben aber letztlich ist das was
dort getan dann wurde ein fauler
kompromiss und es ist und bleibt eine
schrott lösung
ja ich möchte noch zu zwei weiteren
themen stellung beziehen die die woche
auch im plenum thema sein werden es zum
einen natürlich die ausufernde inflation
in deutschland und natürlich auch der
russland ukraine krieg der uns alle
natürlich beschäftigt zur inflation wir
erleben ja aktuell inflationszahlen die
wirklich aktuell aus der außer kontrolle
geraten sind und die für immer mehr
bürger auch existenzielle probleme
bereiten die steigerung der
verbraucherpreise die wir aktuell im
märz sehen und gesehen haben übertrifft
mit über 7,3 prozent sogar noch die
letzte rekordwert von vor über 40 jahren
und dabei ist ein großteil der
kostensteigerung in den
wertschöpfungsketten noch gar nicht in
den verbraucherpreisen angekommen das
erleben wir die nächsten tage auch das
ifo institut hat das ja bereits
angekündigt dass immer mehr unternehmen
auch planen ihre
preise die nächsten wochen und monate
deutlich zu erhöhen also dass wir sogar
auf inflationsraten von über zehn
prozent teilweise 15 prozent in einigen
branchen kommen werden und das natürlich
eine enorme belastung für die bürger für
die mittelschicht auch bedeutet die
ampel koalition wird uns ja auch
weismachen dass es sich dabei um eine
folge der ukraine krise des krieges
handelt und das ist aber ganz
offensichtlich and auch falsch denn die
inflation war bereits vor dem ausbruch
der kampfhandlungen auf einem rekordhoch
gestiegen zum beispiel und das sind mit
die gründe der expansiven
ezb-politik der geldpolitik die hierzu
der plünderung des mittelstandes der
mittelschicht auch geführt haben auch
die verfehlte klimapolitik die wir jetzt
aktuell erkennen ist der deutschen
bundesregierung anzukreiden auch der
regierung der vor regierung merkel die
hier klar neben den kohle und den den
den den
den der den kohleausstieg und auch den
ausstieg aus der kernenergie befördert
hat das ist natürlich folgen genau die
jetzt auch dazu beitragen dass diese
preissteigerung
vorangetrieben werden und natürlich auch
die umfangreichen sanktionen abgaben die
die inflation in die höhe treiben
tatsächlich ist es ein großer teil
dieser inflation im haus gemacht die
auswirkung des innen krieges verschaffen
das wie ein katalysator die staatliche
preistreiberei bei den energiekosten des
halbherzige entlastungspaket was wir vor
14 tagen hier gesehen haben das wird
mittlerweile zur makulatur bereichen
weil es absolut nicht ausreicht die
bürger wirklich zu entlasten hier haben
wir wirklich umverteilungs maßnahmen die
in kraft getreten sind die eben nicht
dazu beitragen die bürger aktuell so
schnell wie möglich zu entlasten unser
vorschlag und auch unsere ersten
schritte auf der acht die
bundestagsfraktion gehen dahin dass wir
die mehrwertsteuer auf treibstoffe und
auf die grundnahrungsmittel senken das
wäre eine sofortmaßnahme sowie die
abkehr und den irrweg der energiewende
beenden das ist aktuell der gebot der
stunde um den druck von den bürgern und
auch der mittelständischen wirtschaft zu
nehmen wies im übrigen viele europäische
länder nachbarländer uns gleich machen
so weiter also kino copala auch damals
wohl ein bisschen härter rausgehen denn
wenn sie mitgezählt haben meine damen
und herren dann haben sie es gemerkt
dass fehlt da noch eine fraktion nehme
ich die linksfraktion am ihrer mohammed
mahdi heißt die fraktionsvorsitzende und
auch sie hat sich vor der sitzung
geäußert natürlich auch zu den untaten
in butter
die bilder aus butscher die erschüttern
uns alle
und auch sie zeigen die unermesslichen
greuel dieses krieges und das was da
geschehen ist in butter das muss
umfassend aufgeklärt werden die
schuldigen müssen vor einem
internationalen gerichtshof vorstellig
werden sie müssen sich das zur
verantwortung ziehen kriegsverbrechen
dürfen niemals ungesühnt bleiben und
daher ist auch vollkommen richtig dass
jetzt die ukrainische
generalstaatsanwaltschaft
mit den ermittlungen beauftragt worden
ist
das unterstützen wir voll und ganz und
wir bleiben dabei das muss aufgeklärt
werden und die verantwortlichen müssen
natürlich zur rechenschaft gezogen
werden
jetzt werden ja in deutschland auch die
stimmen lauter die sagen als folge vor
diesem von diesem schrecklichen krieg
müsse es jetzt ein energie embargo geben
also keinerlei
da es öl keine kohle lieferung mehr aus
russland
ich sag mal
auf einer moralischen ebene ist das eine
nachvollziehbare forderung aber man muss
sich hier denke ich bin besonnenheit
zwei fragen stellen nämlich die eine ist
welche konsequenzen hätte das für
deutschland wenn es einmal ab morgen
keinerlei energielieferung mehr aus
russland kämen und die zweite frage ist
ja hätte eine solche maßnahme überhaupt
den gewünschten effekt nämlich dass der
krieg dadurch schneller oder möglichst
sofort ich beendet würde und bei der
ersten frage muss man sagen ein
sofortiges energie embargo würde
deutschland ganz erheblich treffen wir
beziehen im moment 55 prozent von
unserem gas 5 prozent der kohle 35
prozent öl aus russland
ein sofortiger stopp hätte verheerende
auswirkungen auf die deutsche wirtschaft
zum beispiel auf große teile der
chemieindustrie aber auch die
glasproduktion
lieferketten würden unterbrochen werden
es würde nahezu in allen
wirtschaftsbereichen extreme
konsequenzen haben wir haben schon jetzt
eine in firma inflation auf einem
historischen hoch über 7%
lebensmittelpreise explodieren für viele
menschen ist das bereits jetzt eine
riesige last und das institut für
makroökonomie und konjunkturforschung
hat errechnet wenn wir jetzt kein gas
mehr aus russland bekommen wenigstens
die hälfte der dadurch entstehende lücke
durch alternativen geschlossen werden
könnten was absolut nicht absehbar ist
dann würde das bruttoinlandsprodukt um 6
prozent fallen dass wir ein härterer
einbruch als in der finanzkrise oder in
der korona krise das heißt die
auswirkungen werden wären wirklich ganz
verheerend und auf der anderen seite ist
eben die frage hätte es den positiven
also einen positiven effekt weil es
effekt für einen schnellen ausgang
dieses krieges und hier muss man sagen
das ist ausgesprochen zweifelhaft denn
es ist eine tatsache dass
wladimir putin für seinen krieg die
zahlungen von uns in euro nicht benötigt
das kriegsgerät wird in rubel an
geschafft er hat unmittelbar einfluss
darauf die zentralbanken russland kann
in rubel weiterhin drucken das heißt es
ist überhaupt nicht es gibt keinen
ansatzpunkt sie dafür dass ein solches
embargo dazu führen würde dass dieser
krieg früher beendet wird es wird ja die
impfpflicht debatte geben und auch eine
entscheidung zum thema impfpflicht diese
woche im deutschen bundestag parallel
dazu haben wir jetzt gehört dass die
quarantäne verpflichtungen für menschen
die sie mit dem corona virus infiziert
haben dass die freiwillig werden sollen
auch die sollen wegfallen genauso wie ja
die masken pflicht weggefallen ist und
ich kann nur sagen ich kann mich an
dieser stelle wirklich nur an den kopf
fassen das ist an unlogik nicht mehr zu
überbieten alle sanftere maßnahmen wie
die masken pflicht von der wir wissen
dass sie ein sehr effektives mittel ist
um die korona infektions ausbreitung
einzudämmen ist ein effektives mittel
die ist gefallen aber die impfpflicht
ein ganz erheblicher eingriff in
grundrechte von dem ihr übrigens noch
niemand erklären konnte wie das
überhaupt durchgesetzt wird darüber
redet man komischerweise gar nicht wenn
es einen wichtigen punkt darüber wird
nicht gesprochen die impfpflicht
erhebliche eingriffe in grundrechte der
soll jetzt nach wie vor kommen ich finde
es absurd denn wir wissen dass die
impfung leider eben nicht davor schützt
dass man sich mit corona infizieren kann
zumindest nicht bei der jetzigen omikron
variante das wissen wir bereits dass
hier einfach weitergemacht wird und
diese neuen informationen diese
neuentwicklung vollkommen ausgeblendet
werden finde ich absurd und wenn ich
jetzt angucke dass die quarantäne
pflicht wegfallen soll nur noch
freiwillig sein soll dann weiß ich doch
jetzt schon welche konsequenzen das hat
es wird die konsequenz haben dass alle
die beschäftigten die in unsicheren
arbeitsverhältnissen sind die befristet
beschäftigt sind leiharbeiter und so
weiter die werden sich jetzt nicht mehr
krank schreiben lassen die werden druck
von den arbeitgebern bekommen und das
wird dazu führen dass auch hier den
infektionen sich weiter ausbreiten dass
die arbeitsorte immer unsicherer werden
ich finde das absolut unverantwortlich
das sind alles maßnahmen die zu nichts
anderem führen dass das vertrauen in
politik weiter zerstört würde ich finde
es alles in allem unverantwortlich was
die bundesregierung wie im chor oder
management macht das ist meiner ansicht
nach vollkommen ja unsere mut bar und
nicht vertretbar
ja am ihrer mohammed ali die
fraktionsvorsitzende der linken da kann
man ungefähr erahnen wie sie dann am
donnerstag abstimmen wird das wird
sicherlich ein spannender aufregender
tag werden am donnerstag im deutschen
bundestag drei anträge zwei
gesetzentwürfe sie stehen zur abstimmung
und es kann gut sein dass am schluss
keiner dieser fünf abstimmung eine
mehrheit ergibt so dass sich dann quasi
gar nichts ändert das ist fast so ein
bisschen deckungsgleich mit dem was die
afg will die will allerdings alle corona
maßnahmen abschaffen und sagt ja auch
das impfen überhaupt nichts taugt also
das wird eine spannende geschichte
werden schon morgen wird es hier wieder
spannend im deutschen bundestag stellt
sich nämlich der bundeskanzler den
fragen der abgeordneten bei uns zu sehen
ab 12 uhr 45 donnerstag 8 uhr 45 dann
diese spannende abstimmung szenario was
wohl bis zum mittag geht bevor wir dann
gewissheit haben ob es in deutschland
dann eine impfpflicht ab 50 gibt eine
impfpflicht ab 18 jedenfalls ist im
deutschen bundestag nicht durchsetzbaren
wenn man sich auf der welt mal umschaut
dann haben das auch nur die wenigsten
staaten österreich hat eingeführt dann
ausgesetzt
pakistan hatte aserbaidschan hat es aber
sind wirklich wenig staaten im pflicht
ab 50 kennen wir zum beispiel aus
italien da gibt es einige staaten und
wie gesagt am schluss kann es gut sein
dass kein antrag eine mehrheit bekommt
und dass dann der status quo so bleibt
wie er ist denn was im herbst passieren
wird das wissen wir alle nicht meine
damen und herren aber ich weiß jetzt wie
es bei phoenix weiter geht und zwar gebe
ich heute gar nicht so weit weg von hier
in unser studio in berlin und da steht
nämlich mein kollege alfred schier
hallo die bürgerinnen und bürger vor
verbrechen zu schützen ist eine der
wichtigsten